ich habe mir selbst eine challenge gestellt wie
viele kekse schaffe ich mit einem kilogramm also
einer packung mehl das ergebnis seht ihr am
ende des videos ich verrate euch nur so viel
es sind mehr als ihr wahrscheinlich
gerade alle vermutet fang nummer an
ich schreibe euch natürlich wie immer alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben hier unten in die video
beschreibung und ich starte jetzt hier mit
butter ihr könnt auch margarine nehmen wir
nehmen möchte und die sollte wirklich zimmer
warm sein also gut eine stunde vorher aus dem
kühlschrank nehmen und dann geht das jetzt hier
in die rührschüssel in einer küchenmaschine ihr
dürft ihr natürlich auch andere gerät benutzen da
fahren immer noch ganz viele nach dauert dann halt
wirklich nur zwei minuten länger und da gebe
ich dann noch zucker mit dazu vanille extrakt
und gleich nochmal richtig ordentliche prise
salz denn die hebt noch mal den süßen geschmack
ich habe die butter zucker massiert
vier minuten lang schön gemixt auf
fast maximaler geschwindigkeit und jetzt
ist auch richtig schön hell cremig geworden
und da geben wir jetzt die eier nach und
nach rein also ich lag da wirklich eins
rein für das bis es sich verbindet und
20 sekunden ungefähr und gibt dann die
nächsten dazu und sobald das verrät ist
kommt auch schon die packung mit rein
der teig ist fertig der ist sehr weich der
klebt aber auch gar nicht an der oberfläche
habe ich mein ganzes mehr verbraucht ja das
kenne ich jetzt ja auch noch ein denn der darf
ruhig noch so ein bisschen was ihr habt aber
natürlich auch je nachdem wie groß die eier
sind die möglichkeit mit ein bisschen milch nach
zu helfen falls ihr merkt er ist zu trocken weil
wenn er zum beispiel kleine eier verwendet
dann könnt ihr noch so ein esslöffel milch
dazugeben bei mir war das jetzt aber überhaupt
nicht nötig ich mache jetzt so dass die riesen
teig ein hand in der hälfte durch teile damit
es einmal besser verstauen kann im kühlschrank
und dann schön flach andrücken in frischhaltefolie
wickeln und dann je nach dem ich alter kühlschrank
eingestellt ist so ein bis zwei stunden
noch mal richtig schön durch kühlen lassen
so wir starten jetzt mal mit etwas zitrone
ich habe jetzt hier meinen großen tag einmal
in der hand ich werde das jetzt einfach so machen
dass ich mir nur ein drittel davon nehme den rest
könnt ihr dann einfach wer den kühlschrank tun
und der mit zitronengeschmack bekommt entweder
gleich zitronenschalen abrieb reingehen das
funktioniert nur mit ungespritzten zitronen
also nur mit die bio zitronen ich habe leider
keine bio zitronen da wo ich immer welche da hab
aber ihr könnt alternativ auch zitronen passte
nehmen verlegen ich euch gerne wird ziemlich
bei mir im shop oder halt wie gesagt einfach den
schalen abrieb da jetzt gleich mit einem kneten
sobald ihr die zitronen passt so gut eingearbeitet
habe lasst euch da aber auch nicht zu viel zeit
denn die hand wärme tut dem teig jetzt nicht
so gut könnt ihr das ganze auch schon abstechen
trauben groß würde ich jetzt mal sagen also ganz
so ungefähr und dann einfach die kugeln direkt auf
das mit backpapier ausgelegtes backblech geben ich
mache da nämlich gleich noch so eine kleine mulde
rein und dann fühlen wir lemon curt reine schmeckt
so gut und das dürfte tatsächlich auch mit button
die limit plätzchen werden jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze für
zehn bis zwölf minuten gebacken sie dürfen
auch noch ein bisschen hell bleiben damit
sie nicht zu trocken werden und wir machen
direkt weiter keine zeit verschwenden hier
wir machen weiter mit marzipan kipferl und
da nehme ich mir jetzt wieder den teig aus
dem kühlschrank dann nehme ich mir wieder an
dritte weg und dann einfach marzipanrohmasse
dazu raspeln ich habe es so gemacht dass
ich die marzipanrohmasse gerade nochmal in
den kühlschrank getan habe ich glaube dass
sie sich dann einfach besser raspeln lässt
der richtig gut ihr müsst auch mal euren
zeigen welche leute nicht komplett nach
marzipan und jetzt einmal einen ganz
langen strang formen ich kann das auch
einmal halbieren bis zu lang und dann nehmt
euch einfach eine tankkarte oder alternativ
ein messer und sticht euch schonmal immer
gleichmäßig große teile ab und dann einfacher
form einfach kipferl form mit backpapier
ausgelegtes backblech natürlich widerlegen
und anschließend wenn sie gebacken und
ich trug sie später noch in kuvertüre
die marzipan kipferl müssen jetzt noch mal kurz in
den kühlschrank denn der teig ist schon ziemlich
weich geworden durch das ganze kneten natürlich
das ganze rollen und damit sie nicht verlaufen
einmal ganz kurz kühlen für 10 15 minuten und dann
auch bei 180 grad ober unterhitze für zehn bis
zwölf minuten backen ich lasse dann vollständig
auskühlen und nehmen dann wie gesagt noch meine
kuvertüre setzte in der mikrowelle einfach ja
schmelzen und dann die spitzen nochmal rein tunken
so ich nehme jetzt hier nochmal ein drittel und
wert darauf sind klingel machen weil ich finde
auf einem plätzchen teller muss auf jeden fall
was mit zimt dabei sein und da machen wir einfach
folgendes wir werden das jetzt kurz geschmeidig
kneten also wirklich so kurz wie möglich dann
werde ich aus rollen auf frischhaltefolie mit
butter bestreichen und mit zimt zucker bestreuen
der grund warum wir das direkt auf der
folie ausgebreitet haben es einfach der
dass man es viel einfacher auf rollen
kann und jetzt werde ich einfach hier
drin noch mal richtig gut verschließen
dann kommt das bei mir ins gefrierfach
für zehn minuten ihr könnt aber auch für
20 oder 30 minuten in den kühlschrank
legen dann einfach scheiben runter
schneiden und ab aufs backblech damit
die bauzeit für die zim kriege beträgt ungefähr
elf bis zwölf minuten ist natürlich immer ein
auge drauf haben bei gleicher temperatur
übrigens 180 grad ober unterhitze achtet
darauf dass sie nicht zu dunkel werden dann
werden sie halt trocken und ich mach jetzt
hier weiter mit der zweiten platte sozusagen
und dann nehme ich mir jetzt gleich erstmal
gut die hälfte will schon fast sagen und werde
mir den kakao brauen einfärben das heißt ich
nehm bacau das ist der stark endgültiger
sinnig der trinkaus und da könnt ihr dann
auch noch immer ein bisschen milch dazugeben
weil der ist halt sehr trocken und verbindet
sich besser wenn ihr dann schlückchen
weil sie noch ein bisschen mehr dazu gibt
und schon haben wir einen kakao teil davon
brauche ich jetzt nicht alles also von diesem
cacau tag ging ich mir auch so ungefähr
ein drittel weg den rest baur ich gleich
dann könnte ich mir den hellen vanille tag
nochmal kurz geschmeidig und zeigt euch dann
wie ihr solche worlds macht also einfach
nur hübsche kekse da müsste einfach ganz
viele kugeln rollen und dann gibt es da einfach
eine ganz einfache technik wie er das hinbekommt
die cookies wandern jetzt bei 180
grad ober unterhitze für circa 15
minuten in den backofen die brauchen
wir auch keine kühe zeit vorher das ist
alles kein problem ich habe sie vorher
noch so ein bisschen flach angedrückt
ich mache jetzt weiter mit leckeren pistazien
keksen ich wollte auch gerne das auf dem teller
so ein bisschen buntes drauf ist wir haben
jetzt gelb wir haben brown habe einfach
nur beige oder beziehungsweise weist und
was grün ist darf nicht fehlen in dem ich
jetzt meine pistazien das ist übrigens
die aus dem shop aus gaziantep verlinke
euch alles unten in der box die gebe ich
jetzt in meinen mixa falls sie seien mixa
nicht habt einfach mit einem nudelholz in
gefrierbeutel draufhauen bis es richtig
schön klein wird oder richtig fein hacken das
funktioniert auch hauptsache sie wenn klein
also meine aussage mit dem gefrierbeutel ziehe
ich auf jeden fall zurück denn die sollten schon
sehr fein sein adaption der ofen ich wollte
nur kurz die pistazien mit marzipan und ein
bisschen puderzucker verkneten wohl aber kurz
die kekse von vorhin raus und dann geht's weiter
die sind
fertig wenn du willst dich doch den
weg um ahmed nehmen 3 das ist alles
das wird alles länger dauern lassen okay
da mache ich jetzt weiter also für zucker
darf nicht fehlen lässt sich auch ein
bisschen besser verkneten verknetet so
lange bis ihr quasi grünen marzipan
nein grünen bist a 10 marzipan habt
jetzt habe ich mir aus hellem steigt wieder
das ist wieder ich habe mir diesmal also
rechteckig ein bisschen das ganze ausgerollt
aber wieder unter der frischhaltefolie das
heißt wir wollen gleich wieder auf wie bei den
zimt städtchen die habe ich jetzt genannt ich
weiß es gar nicht mehr auf jeden fall müsst
euch nicht so viel mühe geben denn am ende
wird sowieso hübsch und man sieht gar nicht
wie ihr das ausgerollt hab ich nehme jetzt
hier mein marzipan strang werden doch noch
ein bisschen dünner rollen dann gebe ich
den in die mitte soll das ganze auf und
dann werde ich noch mal für zehn minuten
ins gefrierfach geben weil ich finde man
kann es doch einfach besser durchschneiden
die pistazien kekse brauchen jetzt ebenfalls bei
180 grad ober und unterhitze circa 15 minuten
sondern sich ganz auf die dicke an da müsste oder
dürfte kann halt immer mal wieder kontrollieren
ich mache jetzt weiter mit unseren letzten
plätzchen ich habe hier ja noch cacau teig
und das werden man die plätzchen da habe ich
jetzt hier gemacht man denn die könnte jetzt
ganz einfach ein arbeiten anschließend werde
ich den teig auf der arbeitsfläche ausrollen
und dann in ganz grobe stückchen schneiden mandeln
nochmal on top geben da könnte ja gehobelte nehmen
oder gestiftete und dann kommen sie auch aufs
backblech und werden bei gleicher temperatur
so acht bis zehn minuten gebacken also sie sind
schon bei mir sehr dünn aber wie gesagt bei der
bei den bucks zeiten immer ein auge drauf haben
manchmal brauchen sie auch eine minute länger
also auf dem teller weise ist
nicht aber insgesamt habe ich
250 tags darauf an wie viel mehr ich gebraucht hat
fast die hälfte ist also ein aus einem kilo mehl
bekommt jetzt nach dem rezept echt 250 kekse damit
könnt ihr so viele familien beschenken oder selbst
vernaschen größeres von europa schocken wird diese
ganze tisch voll ist ja wasser da gibt's auch noch
verschiedenste kekse also nur seinen stab der 1
ich glaube mir den abend am 1 auf einer hochzeit
ist okay mit schoko stage lustig und ich bin voll
der zitronen fällen also selbst detail ist heftig
zeit noch nicht so dass er hat also so schwer
traktoren jetzt eigentlich direkt am mikrofon so
alles mehr machen müssen wo ich meine da war hier
so toll und die mordenden dankeschön so
ich mit sagen mach das gerne macht es
unbedingt sogar nach ohne ich freue
mich über eure fotos auf instagram
richtig konnten abschließen jetzt ein café
paar kekse und darm erklärt weil hansa fans
zwar 12 uhr morgens bei der ernte ist auf
jeden fall gerettet der nächste tag also
ich wünsche euch viel spaß und nachmachen und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten oder selbst